Générique
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous.
Heureux de vous retrouver pour
"Parlement hebdo".
- Kathia Gilder: Pour commenter ce
film riche de la semaine, nous
sommes avec Ian Boucard.
- Ian Boucard: Bonjour.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous êtes député
Les Républicains du Territoire de
Belfort.
- Alexandre Poussart: Tous les
yeux sont tournés vers le Conseil
constitutionnel, qui va rendre en
fin de journée sa décision
sur la réforme des retraites.
Même si le texte est validé, cela
ne signifie pas forcément la fin
de la mobilisation sociale.
La droite doit voter une loi pour
soutenir les forces de l'ordre.
Le Parlement s'est opposé à la
nomination
d'un politique.
- Kathia Gilder: Dans quelques
heures, les neuf sages du Conseil
constitutionnel vont rendre leur
verdict sur la réforme des
retraites.
Ils diront si le texte est
conforme ou pas à la Constitution.
- Gouvernement et opposition se
préparent à toutes les hypothèses.
- Le président de la République ne
doit pas promulguer la loi.
- Ce ne sera pas parce qu'une
décision est prise qu'il y aura
une forme d'abdication.
- La mobilisation continuera au
moins jusqu'au 1er mai.
- C'est une réforme injuste et
brutale dans son application.
On a encore la possibilité de
s'exprimer, notamment au 1er mai.
- La décision du Conseil
constitutionnel portera aussi sur
le référendum d'initiative
partagée.
Cela serait un argument
supplémentaire pour poursuivre la
bataille contre la réforme des
retraites.
- Kathia Gilder: Ian Boucard, vous
étiez parmi les députés qui ont
voté la censure du gouvernement.
Vous pensez que le Conseil
constitutionnel va invalider la
réforme des retraites?
- Ian Boucard: On le saura dans
quelques heures, mais jamais dans
la Ve République, une décision du
Conseil constitutionnel n'aura été
aussi attendue.
Cette réforme concerne chaque
français.
C'est une décision qui est très
attendue et qui portera sur une
réforme qui fait polémique depuis
plusieurs mois.
Personne ne sait ce qui va sortir.
Je pense qu'une partie du texte
sera censurée.
Mais j'ai peur que le Conseil
constitutionnel ne fasse que
mettre du sucre glace sur un
plateau très amer.
C'est la mesure d'âge qui crispe,
et qui fait la mobilisation
sociale.
Elle ne devrait pas être annulée.
Je suis cependant un opposant
résolu à cette réforme des
retraites.
Mais je suis inquiet quand je vois
les déclarations de certains
collègues de la gauche et de La
France Insoumise qui remettent en
cause le Conseil constitutionnel.
- Kathia Gilder: Si la loi est
validée globalement, vous
respecterez la décision?
- Ian Boucard: Evidemment.
Je crois en nos institutions.
Je crois en la République.
Notre système n'est pas une
dictature.
Je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
réforme des retraites, mais le
rôle du Conseil constitutionnel
est de vérifier si la réforme est
constitutionnelle ou non.
Ils ne font pas de politique.
Ce serait grave qu'ils se mettent
à faire de la politique.
- Alexandre Poussart: Ils vont se
prononcer notamment sur la
sincérité du débat parlementaire.
Vous avez eu l'impression que le
débat était sincère?
- Ian Boucard: Je regrette
l'utilisation du 47.1 qui a limité
le débat dans le temps.
Je regrette aussi que la France
Insoumise ait empêché les débats
d'arriver jusqu'à l'article 7 qui
parlait du report de l'âge.
Nous aurions pu gagner ce vote.
Je regrette les mesures dilatoires
qui ont empêché d'aller au fond
des choses.
Après, c'est aux constitutionnels
de raccourcir les débats.
- Kathia Gilder: Les sages du
Conseil constitutionnel vont se
prononcer uniquement en droit.
Est-ce que le contexte politique
ne va pas jouer?
- Ian Boucard: Je ne crois pas et
ce ne serait pas souhaitable.
Il va y avoir la décision
sur la réforme des retraites mais
aussi sur le référendum.
Pour sortir de cette crise
politique et sociale, nous devons
aller jusqu'au référendum.
Je ne vois pas pourquoi il ne
serait pas validé.
La mobilisation sera ensuite pour
réunir les 4,5 millions de
signatures.
Il n'y a que par le vote que nous
pourrons sortir de cette crise.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les
parlementaires de gauche qui
demandent ce référendum
d'initiative partagée ont déposé
une deuxième demande.
- Ian Boucard: Le pays est bloqué.
Je ne vois pas comment on peut
aller au bout de ce mandat.
Il reste encore 4 ans à Emmanuel
Macron.
Je ne vois pas comment sortir de
cette crise, si ce n'est par le
vote.
Je vois que certains appellent à
une dissolution.
Peu importe.
Mais il me semble que le point de
crispation, c'est cette réforme
des retraites.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous feriez
campagne pour ce référendum
d'initiative partagée?
- Ian Boucard: J'aiderais les
citoyens de ma circonscription à
s'enregistrer.
Je les inciterais à voter contre
cette réforme des retraites.
- Alexandre Poussart: Si le
conseil constitutionnel valide
cette réforme des retraites, la
mobilisation doit continuer?
- Ian Boucard: S'il y a un
référendum, il faudra se mobiliser
autrement.
4,8 millions, c'est énorme.
On a vu sur l'aéroport de Paris.
Il y avait à peine 1,3 million de
signatures.
Mais c'est très concernant.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a un risque
que la contestation sociale déjà
très forte, qui se radicalise
encore?
On a vu beaucoup de violence hier.
- Ian Boucard: Il y a un risque
que les Français, à force de ne
pas se sentir entendu, ne croient
plus en grand-chose.
Il faut sortir de cette crise
politique et sociale.
Les mobilisations sont parfois de
plus en plus violentes.
C'est dangereux.
Je vois des factieux qui remettent
en cause les institutions.
Des centaines de milliers de
français manifestent pour porter
un message.
Le problème, c'est qu'à la télé,
on voit les quelques excités qui
cassent et agressent les forces de
l'ordre.
On n'entend plus le message porté.
- Alexandre Poussart: Comment vous
voyez la suite du quinquennat?
Faut-il un remaniement pour
redonner du souffle à ce
gouvernement?
- Ian Boucard: Je suis défavorable
à un contrat de gouvernement avec
Les Républicains.
Il faut se remettre au travail.
Je pense à la justice, à la
police, à l'éducation nationale ou
la santé.
J'appelle au travail sur certains
sujets majeurs.
Mais de manière transparente, pas
dans les coulisses.
Il ne faut pas faire du débauchage
individuel.
Il faut un travail collectif,
transparent.
S'agissant du gouvernement, qui
peut croire qu'Elisabeth Borne
peut faire encore 4 ans?
Je n'ai rien contre elle.
Mais la réforme des retraites a
cramé son capital politique.
Le gouvernement ne peut plus
gouverner notre pays.
- Kathia Gilder: Sans Les
Républicains, le gouvernement est
paralysé.
Vous êtes conscient que vous avez
une responsabilité dans cette
crise politique?
On dit que vous êtes la force
d'appoint de la majorité.
- Ian Boucard: J'ai été élu député
parce que les citoyens de ma
circonscription ont voulu un
député d'opposition, et j'avais un
candidat MoDem face à moi.
Il faut savoir d'où viens.
Si on est député, c'est parce que
les gens nous font confiance
et nous ont choisi.
Les gens ont fait un autre choix
que celui de la majorité.
Je ne suis pas un opposant
systématique.
Je vote et appuie certaines lois.
Mais je ne suis pas là pour
appuyer en permanence.
On a beaucoup parlé des députés
Playmobil entre 2017 et 2022.
Je les ai beaucoup critiqués, mais
je suis là pour travailler.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'en
s'opposant à la réforme des
retraites, vous n'êtes pas dans
une opposition politicienne?
- Ian Boucard: Je l'ai dit dans ma
campagne législative, que j'étais
opposé à cette réforme.
Après, c'était dans le programme
de Valérie Pécresse.
Quand on soutien un candidat, on
n'est pas forcément d'accord avec
tout son programme.
Je fais des réunions publiques
encore à 48 heures du premier
tour.
J'étais là jusqu'au bout.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
Gérard Larcher Premier ministre,
ce serait une bonne chose?
- Ian Boucard: S'il y a une
dissolution et que Les
Républicains sont majoritaires à
l'Assemblée nationale, oui.
Mais s'il y a une dissolution, je
ne suis pas certain que nous
serons majoritaires.
- Alexandre Poussart: Dans ce
contexte de tension et de violence
dans les manifestations, le Sénat
a adopté une proposition de
résolution de soutien aux forces
de l'ordre.
Les sénateurs de gauche ont
dénoncé un texte manichéen.
- Ce n'est pas un texte de loi
mais une prise de position très
politique que les sénateurs ont
adoptée mercredi.
La droite et le centre ont
largement voté pour exprimer leur
gratitude et la reconnaissance du
Sénat aux forces de l'ordre.
Une proposition de résolution
déposée par Bruno Retailleau suite
aux violents affrontements de
Sainte-Soline.
- Face à ce déchaînement, nous
avons un devoir, nous, élus.
C'est de dire les choses, de
nommer les choses.
Nous devons prendre parti et
choisir le camp de l'ordre
républicain.
- Le texte a été voté à 250 voix
pour et zéro contre, car la gauche
n'a pas souhaité prendre part au
vote sur un texte qu'elle juge
opportuniste et malvenu.
- Déposer ce texte dans une
période où le travail des forces
de l'ordre est questionné, c'est
déclarer à ceux qui critiquent la
police de circuler.
La critique de la police est
souhaitable et légitime.
- Ils rappellent leur soutien aux
forces de l'ordre.
Les groupes de gauches ont déposé
des propositions de
contre-résolutions.
Les socialistes ont dénoncé
l'ultradroite.
- Est-ce qu'il faut encore
utiliser des armes de guerres qui
ne sont plus utilisées dans
d'autres pays européens comme les
LBD ou les grenades de
désencerclement?
Est-ce qu'il faut utiliser
l'interdiction de manifestations à
outrance comme l'a fait le
ministre de l'Intérieur?
- Une série d'auditions sera
lancée sur les affrontements entre
policiers et manifestants.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous
voteriez un texte similaire à
l'Assemblée?
- Ian Boucard: Sans aucun souci.
Je regrette que l'Assemblée n'ait
pas adopté la proposition de notre
collègue qui remettait en place
des peines planchers pour les
agresseurs des dépositaires de
l'autorité publique.
Je ne suis pas de ceux qui disent:
"Je soutiens, mais..."
Il faut arrêter avec ces petites
nuances.
Quand on attaque un policier ou un
gendarme, on attaque la
République.
Quand je vois les images de ce qui
s'est passé à Sainte-Soline, je
pense que nos collègues sénateurs
ont eu raison de réaffirmer leur
soutien aux forces de l'ordre.
Je suis un peu surpris de la
position de nos collègues
sénateurs de gauche.
Si ça avait été le groupe
Insoumis, je ne serais pas
surpris.
Mais j'entends parfois mes
collègues députés communistes...
- Kathia Gilder: Vous admettez
qu'il peut y avoir des violences
du côté des policiers?
- Ian Boucard: Il peut y avoir des
dérapages individuels qui doivent
être condamnés.
- Kathia Gilder: Pas de violences
policières en tant que telles?
- Ian Boucard: Pas de violence
systémique.
Depuis l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron, on enchaîne les gilets
jaunes, les manifestations des
antivax, les manifestations contre
la réforme des retraites...
Le climat social est épouvantable
depuis son élection.
Les policiers et gendarmes ont été
très peu soutenus sous Christophe
Castaner.
Il y a malheureusement des
dérapages et des interventions qui
ont pu mal se passer mais dans
leur immense majorité, il y a un
travail remarquable des policiers
et gendarmes.
Quand il y a des dérapages, des
problèmes, y compris du côté des
manifestants, c'est à Paris.
Il y a un contexte particulier.
En province, j'ai vu des
manifestations avec beaucoup de
monde et aucun incident.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y a quand
même eu des violences à
Sainte-Soline dans la
manifestation d'opposition a un
projet de mégabassines.
Ce type de violence n'est-il pas
en échec de la stratégie de Gérald
Darmanin?
- Ian Boucard: Ce serait facile de
lui jeter la pierre.
Ce sont des écolos
particulièrement radicaux.
Ce sont des gens extrêmement
inquiétants que l'on a vu arriver
avec des armes de guerre.
Ils ne voulaient pas manifester.
Peut-être aurait-il fallu les
arrêter plus tôt.
Je fais partie de ceux qui ne
comprennent pas qu'on ne les ait
pas empêchés d'arriver sur le
site, mais c'était sans doute
souhaitable qu'ils ne soient pas
dans une ville avec des gens
autour.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous êtes pour
interdire certaines armes, comme
les grenades de désencerclement?
- Ian Boucard: On peut aussi se
dire que la police ne devrait pas
être armée ou devrait faire de la
médiation.
Mais il faut être raisonnable et
faire confiance à ceux qui sont
dépositaires de l'autorité
publique.
- Alexandre Poussart: Selon vous,
la gauche complaisante vis-à-vis
des casseurs?
- Ian Boucard: Il y a un vrai
sujet.
J'ai vu votre émission
de la semaine dernière.
Fabien Gay ne m'a pas paru
complaisant du tout avec les
casseurs.
La France Insoumise est
complaisante avec une certaine
forme de radicalisation.
Je dis qu'il faut soutenir nos
forces de l'ordre mais aussi
soutenir les manifestant.
A 99%, les manifestants sont
pacifiques.
Quand vous avez des black blocs,
ils dénaturent le message transmis
par les manifestations.
- Kathia Gilder: Gérald Darmanin
parle de "terrorisme intellectuel
d'extrême gauche" à propos de La
France Insoumise.
- Ian Boucard: Je fais attention à
utiliser ce mot de manière
mesurée.
Notre pays sait ce que c'est que
le terrorisme.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce terme vous
choque?
- Ian Boucard: Je comprends le
fond de ce que veut dire le
ministre et je suis assez
d'accord.
Je n'aurais pas utilisé les mêmes
mots.
- Alexandre Poussart: Gérald
Darmanin a aussi dit qu'il fallait
regarder de plus près les
subventions versées à la Ligue des
droits de l'homme, qui observe les
manifestations et critique parfois
la police.
- Ian Boucard: Ils critiquent tout
le temps l'action de la police.
Je ne sais pas s'il faut remettre
en cause les subventions a la
Ligue des droits de l'homme.
Si demain, l'association sort du
périmètre qu'elle est censée
défendre, on peut y regarder.
Je n'ai pas vocation à attaquer la
Ligue des droits de l'homme.
Si le ministre de l'Intérieur
estime que ça le regarde, il a été
choisi pour ça.
- Kathia Gilder: On va passer au
troisième thème de cette émission.
Boris Ravignon ne sera pas
reconduit à la tête de l'Ademe, sa
candidature a été rejetée par le
Parlement.
Le maire de Charleville-Mézières
avait été choisi en vertu du
pouvoir de nomination du président
de la République.
Les sénateurs ont refusé de donner
leur feu vert à la reconduction de
Boris Ravignon.
- En décembre, vous n'aviez obtenu
votre validation qu'à cinq voix
près avec même un bilan négatif.
L'un des reproches qui vous ont
été adressés à l'époque étaient
votre choix de cumuler la
présidence de l'Ademe avec votre
mandat de maire et de président de
l'agglomération.
Vous avez dit que vous exercerez
vos mandats sur votre temps
personnel.
Qu'en pensent vos habitants?
- Le fait de rester en contact
avec le terrain a un intérêt.
Un certain nombre de personnes ou
de groupes ont cette position.
Le cumul de fonctions que je
représente est légal.
Il est tout à fait permis par les
textes.
- Kathia Gilder: Boris Ravignon
était le candidat de l'Elysée.
Proche d'Emmanuel Macron, élu LR,
il s'est rallié à Emmanuel Macron.
Est-ce un revers pour Les
Républicains ou pour Emmanuel
Macron?
- Ian Boucard: C'est la première
fois sous la Ve République que le
Parlement rejette un candidat.
Il faut les trois cinquièmes.
Il faut 50% pour rejeter un
candidat.
J'ai vu des collègues du groupe LR
voter contre monsieur Ravignon.
C'est qu'il y a un problème.
Son choix de cumuler la présidence
de l'Ademe et son mandat de maire
est problématique.
- Alexandre Poussart: Boris
Ravignon a réagi et a dénoncé le
sectarisme des parlementaires
Républicains.
C'était son parti d'origine.
Il a décidé de rallier Emmanuel
Macron pendant sa campagne
présidentielle.
Ce n'est pas un règlement de
comptes politiques des
Républicains?
- Ian Boucard: Il y avait un sujet
au sein du MoDem, de Horizons et
sans doute de Renaissance pour la
nomination de Boris Ravignon.
C'est facile de cracher sur ses
anciens alliés.
- Kathia Gilder: Boris Ravignon a
dit que ce n'était pas un problème
mais un atout de cumuler les
mandats et qu'il pouvait apporter
son expérience du terrain.
Est-ce que c'est un atout ou un
problème de cumuler comme ça
l'Ademe, un mandat de ville et un
mandat de président
d'agglomération?
- Ian Boucard: La présidence de
l'Ademe est un mandat à temps
plein.
- Kathia Gilder: Il a dit qu'il
administrerait la ville sur son
temps libre.
- Ian Boucard: C'est une fausse
réponse.
Quand on est président de l'Ademe,
on voyage en permanence.
On est attendu sur l'ensemble des
territoires de la République.
Il faut arrêter de se moquer des
gens.
On ne peut pas cumuler la
présidence de l'Ademe et le mandat
de maire de Charleville-Mézières.
On ne peut pas tout faire en
permanence.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous n'êtes pas
pour un retour aux députés-maires?
- Ian Boucard: Je pense que
l'Assemblée et le Sénat ont sans
doute perdu en compétences avec le
fait de ne plus avoir des élus qui
sont en même temps maires.
Notamment dans ce mandat, où il
n'y a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée, je ne vois pas
comment je pourrais être maire à
côté avec notre charge de travail.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'il
y a un problème de connexion entre
la majorité présidentielle et les
territoires?
- Ian Boucard: Si le groupe
Renaissance a autant baissé entre
les élections, c'est qu'il y a
sans doute un détachement de leur
circonscription.
Je pense que c'est le problème de
tous ceux qui fonctionnent en
vagues.
En 2017, c'était Emmanuel Macron.
En 2022, c'était Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen.
Il y aura sans doute ce sujet
aussi en 2027.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron est connecté
avec le terrain?
On lui reproche de prendre des
décisions envers et contre tous.
- Ian Boucard: Je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a jamais été
réellement connecté aux Français.
Le peuple français, en tout cas,
n'est plus du tout connecté à
Emmanuel Macron.
Il reste encore 4 ans de mandat.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il reste
encore 4 ans de mandat.
- Ian Boucard: Il doit arrêter les
petites phrases méprisantes.
- Kathia Gilder: Merci beaucoup.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA